j'hésite entre scandaleux et lamentable
et en fait c'est honteux on
instrumentalise les enfants et ça me moi
ça me choque je trouve ça juste
enfin ça devrait être presque interdite
les enfants sont des sortes de bêtes de
concours
on leur demande de choisir des
compagnons des amoureux pour leur maman
et choisissent les hommes sur un
catalogue avec des critères comme si on
choisissait une voiture enfin c'est
juste sidérant à travers d'accords avec
régime barrois qui avec 5 qui a expliqué
que c'était un avc complètement
dangereux c'est en fait les emplois pas
responsable de la vie sentimentale de
leurs parents et après des échecs et à
face et justin a expliqué les
pédopsychiatres elle explique en fait je
pas tout lire ce qu'elle a écrit mais en
gros le gorille c'est qu'effectivement
si ça ne fonctionne pas entre papa et
maman
ils vont sentir responsable portabilité
voilà exactement alors vous vous donnez
pas non plus ma part je n'aime pas du
tout parce que dès les premières minutes
ça ne prend pas manque de rythme manque
d'enjeu et mais quelle mécanique pas
assez un mélange est sur le papier ça se
sent bien sur le soi donc si on sent que
ça bouge pas toi je suis d'accord avec
la pédopsychiatre solaire pour les
auditeurs s'en cache pas du tout juste
avant je me faisais était voué à la fin
j'ai paris afp des mots bien ouais moi
j'aime bien moins moi ça me ça me choque
pas personnellement parce que si ça peut
aider en même temps à rendre heureux des
enfants au travers de leur mère je vois
pas ce que cammas 1 ou 4 choquant
magali vous aimez vous moi j'adore si tu
suivais ça drôle j'ai trouvé l'émission
bien faite elle été bienveillante elle
était rigolote je suis trouvé j'ai enfin
c'est un vrai moment de détente les
questions on les ressent chez les
enfants beaucoup plus naturelle ils ont
une perception de la vie que les adultes
non pas des fois et il pose des
questions qu'on se pose pas et c'est
hyper important pour une maman d'avoir
l'aval de ses enfants
je trouve que c'est la base en fait donc
je vois pas où est le problème l'accord
italienne tamaillon elle me voyait drôle
mais tu peux tu peux en fait tu peux
aussi respecter les enfants un moment
donné et mon prendre ils ont des
questions mais numération avec
non un moment donné vous y rendre à son
vieux c'est un divertissement redescend
sans relation vraiment vous parler sans
si on est sans wc débit s'est calmée des
biens et des enfants qui témoigne de st
on n'a qu'à faire trouver une maîtresse
pour papa aussi au nepad
il a pas tort